So there are lots of different ways you can try to
measure the bandwidth that you're getting over your Internet connection. I'm
going to show you one that's provided by CNET. This is not
necessarily that accurate and it'll depend where you are. But you
can go to the CNET site, Internet Speed Test with hyphens
between Internet, speed, and test. Pick your location. I'll deal with
work, and it will try sending some messages to figure out
what your bandwidth is. And, you can see that I'm getting 44,000
kilobits per second, it says kbps here. So that's
44 megabits per second. We can try again, see
if we get the same result. And we try it a second time, we get 31 megabits per
second, or 31.7. We can try again and we get 62. So we can see that it is
varying each time we try it. And bandwidth does
vary. You're sharing connections on the network with other people,
they may be doing different things. There are lots of reasons
why the bandwidth that you measure varies, but if you try
this test you'll see what you get. And we're going to have
a quiz. This is more of a survey than a quiz. But,
we're curious to see what bandwidth you're getting. So, try a
bandwidth test and see what the result is, and the quiz
will ask you to report that to us. So, this isn't
really a quiz. It's more of a survey. But the question is,
what is your bandwidth? And you can use one of the tools
we provided links to, to figure out what your bandwidth is. And
the boxes give you a choice of ranges. And if you can
get greater then 200 megabits per second were you live, I'm very jealous.